hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast better care with better
knowledge presented by Rupert yep
associate director genetic disease
informatics at kaijin I'm Alexis Krause
of leverets and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
kyochon for more information about our
sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
yep I will now turn the presentation
over to him
thanks Alexis and thanks lab roots for
allowing me this opportunity to talk
about some of the exciting things here
that are happening at the kaijin
bioinformatics what a lot of folks don't
realize is that KY gene actually has a
thriving bioinformatics business but our
business is really about the offering of
knowledge as opposed to purely by
informatics algorithm and so this is why
I talk about the theme of our product as
a better care with better knowledge so
the first thing I want to talk about is
this clinical blind spot as more patient
samples get sequence around the world
we're starting to uncover more novel
variants from various patients and
patient populations and in this bubble I
try and depict the universe as possible
human mutations as the universe of all
possible human mutations of course we're
just starting on that endeavor to
uncover all these mutations and you've
got your scientist that has their own
domain of knowledge which is fairly
limited and compared to what's out there
but then you've got these crowdsource
efforts such as clinvar that try to
aggregate this information as well there
is more organized efforts such as hgmd
that's been around for quite a while
that has work to curate all that
knowledge from published literature and
then finally the hygiene knowledgebase
really aggregate information from public
sources such as clinvar Omen and other
public data sources as well as public
private data sources such as hgmd and so
to my knowledge the kaijin knowledgebase
really represents the most inclusive of
all knowledge sources out there to bring
you as much information and to be as
comprehensive as possible on all
possible known human mutations
to that and I want to just throw out
some numbers kaijin had acquired several
companies including ingenuity bio-based
CLC and more recently omics table and in
aggregate these organizations have now
over 13 million knowledgebase findings
we aggregate data from over 30 different
data sources across 20,000 disease
classes and our knowledge base and our
applications have been used in over
30,000 publications additionally our
platform has now been used to analyze
over 750,000 human samples which to my
knowledge is the most largest experience
of looking at human samples from a
genetic standpoint where do we get a lot
of this information this slide really
talks about some of the data sources
that we get our information from some
are public sources are in the white
bubbles here some are proprietary
sources such as ANOVA which is a
healthcare system that have made some of
their clinical cases available to us but
some of them is our own internal manual
curation efforts where we read
scientific and clinical papers to pull
out things like clinical case counts and
then also from sequencing labs such as
Santa Jean that have made their cases
available through a database called sent
to MD and so the you know these public
and private data sources really
represent sort of our effort in
aggregating the world's knowledge into
the knowledge base
now when we talk about knowledge
clinical knowledge we typically talk
about clinical breath and clinical depth
a clinical breast can be defined as how
large is the domain of knowledge and
that can be measured by for example the
number of unique genes that are curated
or the number of variants that are
curated clinical death however is really
talking about how rich or deep is the
knowledge that we're curating and one
way to measure that is you know the
number of citations associated with each
gene or variant and then within each
citation within each paper what richness
of information are you extracting from
those scientific articles things like
clinical case counts how many patients
were affected or how many were
unaffected if there was drug information
what was the drug what was the dose used
how many of those patients were
responding to the drug and how many
warrants so all that useful information
is manually curated and entered into our
knowledge base so when we take a look at
the breadth of coverage currently our
knowledge base has knowledge on variants
across over 18,000 genes in the human
genome that represents close to 90% of
the human genome and if you take a look
at to see where some of that information
is from you can see that some of those
gene information we get from clinvar
some we get from hgmd but there's a
large percent of that information that
is through our own organic curation
effort and so folks who are just using
clinvar alone are missing out on more
than half of the variants that are one
and half the genes that are known to the
kaiju knowledge mates but also the hgmd
further if we take a look at the number
of variants that are captured in the
knowledge base we have annotations
across almost 1 million variants and as
you can see more than half of those are
exclusive to the knowledge base so again
if if folks are just
using clinvar they are missing out on
more than 50% of the information that
could be having access through our
knowledgebase
as an example of how useful this
information is we took a hypothetical
panel of fifty nine genes the ACMG 59
and compared the total number of
variants that you would get if you were
to just rely on for example the clinvar
database or just the HTM D compared to
the knowledgebase the clinvar
the knowledgebase has more than twice
the number of variants covered in the
knowledgebase compared to clinvar and
even with hgmd folks are still missing
out on maybe 20% 27% when we take a look
at the number of publications clinvar
doesn't really have publication
information but even with you're just
relying on hgmd you're missing out on
four times the amount of information
because the knowledge base really
strives to be as comprehensive as
possible and to try and uncover almost
every publication for those particular
genes that are ever published in the
scientific literature and as a result we
have many more publications for those
particular genes and variants that are
found in those 59 genes so what is the
importance of having access to
comprehensive and timely information I
want to talk about a fairly famous case
in 2007 where a clinical testing lab had
tested a child s DN 1 A mutation and at
the time they classified it as a variant
of unknown significance and because of
that classification the physicians
really didn't alter the child's
treatment and consequently the child
passed away a year later well the mom
wanted to follow up and get some more
information and when she pulled that
report she realized that for that
particular mutation that's the lab at
the time should have noticed or should
had access to two publications at the
time of that test and she claims that
back in June 2006 in March of 2007 there
were two papers that provided sufficient
evidence that might have changed the
classification of her child's mutation
her claim is that this evidence and in
fact there was a March 2007 paper that
had an exact patient with the same
mutation in the same phenotype that her
son had and her claim was that had the
lab had access to this knowledge they
probably would have classified that
mutation as pathogenic or likely
pathogenic and if that had happened then
the physicians might have altered the
course of the treatment for her son and
their son might still be alive and so
that case is undergoing litigation right
now but it's just an example of this
blind spot where the labs didn't get
access to as much information as they
could in a timely manner
so really the take-home message is that
whenever you're doing any clinical
testing you really want access to the
most comprehensive and timely knowledge
in order to do a proper assessment now
what can you do with this additional
knowledge well one of the challenges
with clinical testing is identifying
these novel variants and trying to
understand the significance of those
variants when there's not enough
evidence clinicians classify these
variants as a variant of unknown
significance and these are really
challenging because doctors really don't
know what to do with these types of
variants it's equivalent to saying that
you know I'm not exactly sure whether
this is a good or a bad thing and so any
effort to reduce the number of V u SS is
extremely valuable we did a benchmark
study looking across 180 variants for
Lynch syndrome and compared to how
clinvar classifies these variants our
application our knowledge base was able
to look at these 180 and really clarify
that the US
to the point where we were able to
reduce the number of the US by 20% and
reclassified those of us to either
pathogenic likely pathogenic or likely
benign remembering 9 and so this is just
an benchmarking example where more
knowledge brings greater clarity I also
want to talk about our central MD
offering sento MD is the newest member
of the buyer format acknowledged family
it really is a collection of rare
variants based on clinically diagnosed
patients from the Santa gene testing lab
in Germany the unique thing about all
the variants with this Center MD is that
every variant is based on an actual
patient
additionally the variants are classified
by a cap CLIA trained a lab director and
our based on following the ACMG
guidelines and more importantly many of
the variants in this database is not
published anywhere so you would not find
them in for example hgmd
so with that I want to just sort of
highlight the product offering for the
kaijin hereditary disease portfolio it
includes
hgmd ingenuity variant analysis hygiene
clinical insights and sent to m.d. hgmd
is really primarily a survey of all
published literature ingenuity variant
mountains is really a powerful tool to
rapidly identify causal mutations
clinical insights is our clinical
decision support tool and sent to MD is
really the world's largest database of
rare rare disease mutations when I walk
through each one individually
so hgmd really is a strive to be a
comprehensive resource of published
germline disease-causing mutations it
strives to be three things strive to be
comprehensive in that it tries to record
all disease associated germline
mutations that it's in the published
literature it strives to be high quality
in that it's created through manual
curation there's a team of highly
trained genetic experts who read the
scientific literature and extract this
information and it strives to be current
because we update the database on a
quarterly basis now as more sequencing
starts happening around the world what
we're starting to see is an explosion in
a number of uncovered variants and so
the ability to keep up with this
information is really quite challenging
imagine a single lab director even if
they have a very specific domain that
they're interested in it's you know over
the course of several years it becomes
really challenging to be able to keep up
with all the published new mutations
that are coming out and so our team is
really designed to scale and to capture
that knowledge where folks individually
may not be able to and this chart really
takes a look at the progression of
knowledge that is accumulating I the
number of germline mutation mutations
published has really doubled in the last
ten years but we expect the next
doubling to occur in five years or less
the great thing is that
hgmd is available as a web service
there's no software installation that's
needed and available as a subscription
service and you can just launch a
browser to be able to get access to this
knowledge and when you do a search you
come up with a list of mutations and
when you drill into an individual
mutation you get information such as
mutation ID the class of the mutation
a list of the scientific references and
a link out to the publication so that
you can actually read the scientific
article details of the mutation as well
as predictive effects Bateman in silicon
predictors as well as orthogonal
mutations that are in other organisms
how do people use hgmd well typically
there's two ways they approach using
hgmd number one is if they know the
disease or phenotype but want to
understand what genes or mutations are
affected perfect use case is if you're
designing a panel of tests test panel
for cystic fibrosis for example and you
want to understand you know what genes
are associated what hotspots you might
want to put in your panel or if you're
looking for a panel for Lynch syndrome
what genes you might want to include in
that panel and so hgmd could be a great
tool for you to identify a list of genes
and mutations that you want to include
in that panel the other way is where you
already know the gene or mutation will
want to understand what phenotype or
disease is associated so if you're
looking at undiagnosed diseases or
enteric diseases and want to understand
what phenotypes or disease is associated
you can use hgmd to quickly identify
those phenotypes of diseases really hgmd
is designed to help the users save time
by quickly I are going to find that
disease mutation is important phenotype
associated with those mutations here's
an example use case where if you're
looking up all the mutations for cystic
fibrosis one way you can do it is to go
to PubMed type in the term cystic
fibrosis and that will return around
three thousand four hundred and fifteen
articles and if you're able to read
really quickly on the order of five
minutes per article that still takes you
two hundred and eighty four hours and at
the end of that exercise you'll come out
with a list
1383 mutations alternatively if you use
hgmd you could type in the term
statistic fibrosis through the web
browser and within a five-minute search
window return this name number of 13 183
mutations so just to summarize some of
the key benefits of hgmd is really the
assurance that the mutation found in the
HTM d database is disease-causing the
fact that that mutation is found in the
database means that it's disease-causing
so the benefit of that is that it could
take you a really long time to get that
information just let us do that scouring
the literature for you again hgmd can
save you hours and days of surveying the
literature for a particular gene or
disease and using HTM d you could really
identify the disease-causing mutations
within a gene or the mutations
associated with a gene or the mutations
associated with a particular disease
within minutes
and while you know hgmd is a paid-for
subscription service you do save money
from the amount of time that you could
be that you would have spent surveying
the literature but also that you don't
need to subscribe to every journal
article we can just find the article
that you need and then you can just go
and purchase that one article as opposed
to just the entire description next I
want to talk about injunuity various
analysis which is really a tool to
rapidly identify the root cause of
specific disease or phenotype now that
folks have started sequencing whole
exomes and genomes because the cost of
such efforts are much reduced we're
starting to see a lot of folks that are
using whole exome and genome to try and
diagnose rare diseases undiagnosed
diseases looking across not just the
effective individual but maybe in a trio
where you're looking at the effective
individual and their parents often times
when you're sequencing the genome you're
looking on the order of millions four to
five million variants and it's really
hard to know which set of variants are
responsible for the phenotype or the
symptoms that is presented in the
patient with a tool like ingenuity
variant analysis you can quickly filter
down from literally millions of variants
down to the ten bits that are likely
causing the disease and we do this
through a set of steps where you can
reduce variants through common-sense
questions like you know show me only
variants that are not present in the
general population because resume ibly
is they're present in the general
population it's not causing disease and
that's what the common variance filter
does then you might want to say well
show me variants that have no obvious
effect on
protein because if it doesn't effect a
protein it probably isn't going to
impact disease or cause disease those
tools up there are probably not unique
to IBA and a competent automatic team
can probably reproduce a pipeline that
does that the lower portion though is
really making use of the knowledge base
where you can identify relationships
between disease is pathway biomarkers
and so forth and so these filters down
here really allow you to granularly
filter down to the few variants that are
likely to cause disease and I'll walk
you through some of those filter
settings so again very analysis IBA is
available it's a web service so no
software is needed to be installed and
on the left here you can see a cascade
what we call a cascade of builders that
allow you to at each step rule out
certain variants and include variants
that are might be that are interesting
for follow up so the first step is just
identifying confidence filter and
confidence filter is essentially saying
you know I only want to look at variants
that I have high confidence in meaning
that they have a good quality score
enough read depth and are not in a noisy
part of the genome where I can't really
trust the data the second step really
the second filter really is asking that
common variance filter where you're
saying I only look at want to look at
rare variants that are likely to be
present in an effective individual and
not in the general population the third
filter allows you to ask questions like
show me only those variants that are
likely to cause disease and you can
filter by pathogenic or likely
pathogenic as defined by ACMG or filter
for those that are present in hgmd or
found in clinvar so these type or oh or
look for variants that are
likely to cause gain-of-function or loss
of function based on evidence in the
literature or based on and silikal
predictors so a lot of these tools a lot
of a sort of filtering criteria is
something that is not easily doable on a
resource that uses public sources so
things like HTM G is probably something
that is not so easy to compute but
certainly to look for things that are
established in the literature unless
you've manually curated a knowledgebase
of scientific literature you would not
be able to do that have a filtering
another really cool filter is to say you
know show me only the mutations that are
present in the child but not in the
parent and you can look in terms of
homozygosity there's like a fatigue
compound has and so forth so this level
of flexibility to ask these types of
questions is really unique to very
analysis then finally you can then rank
those variants based on a list of
phenotypes and see how many of those
phenotypes are matched with that
particular variation we are able to do
that match because we've read scientific
literature and identify various
phenotypes that are associated with
various mutations in the published
literature and then once you identify
that short list of variants on the right
you can click to see more detail and
that will ease that will quickly bring
up the supporting literature for those
particular variants essentially the
annotations of that variant including
the the published literature that
matches with that marry and you can just
click on those links to go and read
those papers and look at the evidence
yourself to see whether you believe that
particular mutation is relevant for the
disease or phenotype that you're
studying so again the key benefits of
variant analysis really is that it
allows the biologists to do this type of
querying and hypothesis testing on their
own without the need for scripting or
programming
researchers really can control is the
the the filtering settings and do
iterative hypothesis testing through an
intuitive graphical user interface it
puts the variants and genes into
biological context such that you can ask
that question given this list of
variants in my short list and the list
of phenotypes that I see show me only
those variants now that have any
relationship to the phenotype that I'm
looking at it so that sort of filtering
based on phenotype in biological context
is unique to very analysis and finally
because the very analysis tapped into
the knowledge base it really gives you
access to the world's most comprehensive
knowledge base to to answer these
questions but don't take our word for it
we have a lot of researchers around the
world who have been using very analysis
now and they they swear that this tool
provides valuable resources to quickly
identify and really save time but also
in some cases this knowledgebase allows
them to connect the dots and create new
hypotheses from their data
next I want to talk about our clinical
decision support platform called
hydrogen clinical insights it's a tool
that's used with at least several use
cases rare hereditary diseases
hereditary cancers and somatic oncology
the unique thing about the hydrogen
clinical insights is that it
incorporates not just the ACMG
classification scheme but also the amp a
skullcap guidelines for tearing or
somatic cancers and it uses a computed
classification and tearing scheme in
order to automate the classification and
tearing of hereditary and somatic cancer
cases
it again is a web-based application with
a graphical user interface that makes it
really easy to quickly identify the
variants of interest to generate patient
reports and to make clinical decisions
on it provides instant access to the
evidence so for example this particular
variant was classified or computed to be
pathogenic and it provides evidence such
as the effect on the protein any report
in clinical cases that have been seen
before either in the lab or in other
laboratories so in this particular
example it said that this particular
variant has been identified in clinvar
and cosmic and in hgmd as well as
information on rarity in the general
population and in silikal predictions
underneath to understand how that
classification of pathogen is became
about you can click to eyes until I am
to look at the criteria that are
triggered and so in this particular case
this variant had triggered PBS 1 p.m. 2
and P P 3 class criteria and you can
click the under to look at the
scientific literature to understand
where those
criteria come from in somatic workflows
you can actually see the number of
patients that have been reported with
that same mutation and if you click on
those particular mutations on those
particular patient icons you can
actually get the list of publications
that refer to those particular patient
cohorts in ink and then you can drill
further into identify to read about
those particular studies once you've
done your due diligence of looking
across the literature and the clinical
cases you can then review some of the
scientific literature just to see
whether you believe the criteria that
are triggered and the supporting
evidence and when all that information
when you've done that due diligence you
can then begin to sign out or you could
in this case look at some of the
literature and say you know I really
believe this case believe this
publication or you could say that you
don't believe this publication I might
want to exclude this from consideration
in future cases and so all of that
information can be captured to really
streamline the workflow for the next
time you encounter this particular
mutation once you've done all that work
you're ready to sign out and to do that
you can just quickly select that
particular case and do a sign out and
print a PDF of that report and we can
customize that creating PDF report with
your particular labs logo and the
information that are created so that you
can deliver the report to the requesting
physician so qci Kaiser clinical insight
really takes advantage of the knowledge
base to look across as many genes as
possible and because we have knowledge
of really close to over 23,000 genes it
really gives you the assurance that you
have access to the most comprehensive
resources if you're looking at whole
eggs
or Gino's because we've got knowledge of
an experience of having seen over 700
700 thousand patients you can benefit
from the experience of having seen
virtually 700 thousand patients by
virtue of tapping into our knowledge
base something else I want to highlight
is that because of our manual curation
and our experience of using knowledge
from santa fe database as well as from
other labs we can actually trigger the
ps4 and the BS 4 criteria and this is
important because while many platforms
out there claims they do ACMG assessment
very few actually trigger the PS born to
be export criteria and this criteria
really is to say that you know there has
actually been clinical cases that have
this exact mutation and in this exact
phenotype and when you have real-world
examples that's when you trigger the PS
born to be s4 in the ACMG classification
and the Kaiser knowledgebase
brings that evidence of that most
criteria do get triggered our manual
curation effort really means that we can
identify patients in the published
literature that responds to particular
drugs based on genotype and this really
helps provide confidence in the trigging
triggering of those ASCO capturing
calculations we also have access to a
broad mix of ethnic populations that are
unique to the knowledge base and this is
because we have access to certain ethnic
cohorts that are not publicly available
and this really gives researchers
especially for those under represented
ethnicities a better way to discriminate
between benign polymorphic mutations
from actual
mutations now for those of you who
already have their own in-house pipeline
and reporting system and don't need the
full power of hydrogen clinical insight
you can actually access the
knowledgebase through our API and so
this is another option of getting access
to the knowledge base as opposed to
buying a full-blown hydrogen clinical
insight so the way you would do that is
use your pipeline to identify a short
list of variants send those variants via
API call to our knowledge base and then
we would return that variant with all
the knowledge we have on those variants
including our comprehensive computation
of ACMG or a methanol cap guidelines so
again to summarize really that the value
of qci is really to allow your
organization to scale and grow your
testing volume and we can do that
through the interface or through the
flexible API because we've got
experience of looking at there's a
mistake here over 700,000 patients in a
small lab can really scale up and
execute to the same level as a more
established large lab we also make the
ACMG and a methanol cap computations
transparent by providing the evidence
behind them computation so it's not a
black box it's one of the hallmark of
our offering that we make everything
transparent in how we calculate those
those classifications and really ask
around
how many platforms actually trigger the
ps4 and the ps4 classification because
unless they actually have that evidence
from prior labs or from the published
literature it's it's really hard to make
use of that criteria in ACMG
classification
and finally I want to talk about scent
OMD which is our new database scent OMD
really is the world's largest mutation
database of rare diseases it now
contains over 6 million unique variants
from over representing over billion
identified alleles the patient samples
have been sequence based on Sanger
methods or NGS methods or PCR methods
this also some supporting biochemical
analysis as well and more importantly
every patient in that database has been
consented to be recontacting so this is
really valuable for pharma and biotech
research who identifies new particular
genetic marker and may want to follow up
with those patients for additional
studies or even a recruitment in patient
trial as I said that the lab directors
classify all these variants based on
established ACMG guidelines and based on
looking at public sources but also their
repositories unpublished data as well
and when they get updates every quarter
and those updates really have can also
result in reclassification of past
variants and typically it's around 2
percent that get reclassified when we
take a look to see and how many of these
variants are known in the published
literature we see a very large
significant part of those variants that
are not found in the published
literature so in aggregate sent to empty
contains their own 58% web parents that
are not found anywhere else but if you
look at certain rare diseases that level
unpublished variants can vary as high of
69 percent or as low as 41 percent
so sent OMB is available as a web
service so it's a web page you log into
you can identify variants based on
genotype or based on phenotype to do
Phoenix to do a genotype search you just
type in the gene of interest and it will
return a list of variants associated
with that gene and you just activate a
very in order to identify details within
that variant so details that you get
access to are for example how many
patients have been seen with that
particular variant ethnicity of those
patients you can drill into the
individual and identify co-occurring
co-occurring mutations with that
particular individual if you want to
look at the variants see how the lab
directors of Santa Jean classified that
and their rationale for classifying that
particular mutation and then also look
at other individual effective
individuals that they may have that
particular mutation and in many cases
you'll have information on family
members as well
to do a phenotype type research you just
type in phenotype terms and we accept
hpo terms and when you type in those
terms and do it search it will return a
list of patients that are associated
with those phenotypes and when you drill
down to the each individual patient
you'll find that for example these are
the list of genes that are associated
with that particular phenotype and then
the patients that have those particular
variants within those particular genes
and then you can click to identify the
variants within those particular genes
so here's an example use case you want
to find out information about this
particular mutation in the GLA gene so
when you look at public sources you'll
find that using
in silico predictors result in
inconsistent results some predictors
will say that it's benign some
predictors will say it's pathogenic
looking at nomads you see that that's
not this particular mutation has never
been described so nomads not really
helpful looking at other external
databases you don't see that information
as well so you turn to a resource like
Santo MD and when you type that
particular mutation in sent to MD come
back with three individuals with
clinical suspicion the Fabry disease we
send OMB even has enzymatic date data on
all three and shows that in all three of
the Maglev alure decrease and biomarkers
were elevated and this is how the and
then the sent to MD lab director
classified this particular mutation
pathogenic and here's the evidence that
they put together so a tool like sent to
NV for example is able to provide a lot
of detail that public and public sources
was not able to provide another example
is this particular mutation in the GBA
gene we're prediction software said it's
likely benign but at least one published
source says that it's disease-causing so
what does sent know and B say you type
that particular mutation in it
identified 109 individuals and those
were some of those were falafel eyes and
sit with other known pathogenic variants
so based on those evidence the lab
director at set to MD classified
business likely neutral and so it's
really nice to be able to get access to
a database where you can ask that
question has anyone else out there
seeing this particular mutation and if
they did what was the phenotype and
ultimately have that lab interpreted and
so that's really the beauty of sent to
MD sent OMB is is a very large testing
lab in Germany and they are adding on
the order of 20 to 30,000 new patient
sample
per quarter so across the one-year
subscription to send OMB you could be
getting an additional hundred thousand
patients into the database so that one
year gives you access to all that
information that is added on a
continuing basis so the benefits are
really an interactive user interface
allows you to search by DNA type or by
phenotype you can drill into the
individuals and get the information you
can identify you can take a look to see
how the the sent to MD lab director
classifies that those particular
mutations and provide the rationale and
you get access to not just curated data
but unpublished data as well and every
time there's a mutation that is
reclassified you'll get an email
notification to let you know that that
mutation has been reclassified and then
an export function for you to download
and put into your own reports or into
your own pipelines and so with that I'll
wrap it up here and take any questions
that anyone may have thank you
thank you dr. yep's for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left
your presentation type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is how is your ACMG
classification different from other
platforms classification algorithm yeah
well so ACMG published their guidelines
and so they were very clear about how
you go about interpreting that and we
essentially took those rules and made
them into algorithms to compute but
those rules are very specific for
example they say that real-world
evidence will always trump predictor or
in silico evidence and so the unique
thing with how we do our computation is
that we take into account as much
real-world evidence as we can and we
gather and we get that real-world
evidence from manual curation but also
from historical evidence from other labs
who have seen this and examples of
historical evidence from other labs is
the abundant data from sento md but also
from the community of users who use
kaijin clinical insight to look and
bring that knowledge to be shared among
the community of users so you know our
ACMG computation is based on initially
the guidelines that are published by the
ACMG but enhanced with the sort of
manual curation and in some ways machine
learning algorithms that we have that's
part of the knowledge base
next question is what is the source of
the content for your knowledge base yeah
so you know we get it there was a slide
guy talking about it's a combination of
public and private sources so public
obviously everyone has access to public
sources and it's just a matter of doing
the grunt work to to roll those sources
into your pipeline but we also have a
rich private manual curation effort and
I call these manual curation efforts
kind of a moonshot effort because not
many organizations can actually spend
the time and resources do that because
you're not just paying people resources
but you're also paying for journal
subscriptions we have on the order of
over 200 MDS and PhDs who scour the
scientific literature and extract this
information going going through over
2,000 articles a month that information
is then sort of put into the knowledge
base so we get information from both
privately private sources as well as
private sort private manual curated
efforts that we do on our own embarked
yes it looks like we have time for one
more question
why is manual curation so important
compared with the machine learning and
natural language processing yeah so you
know we get a lot of there's a lot of
news these days about machine learning
and deep learning and artificial
intelligence and I just want to give an
example where you could get a machine
learning or natural language processing
algorithm that can redesign to read a a
newspaper article and identify that John
F Kennedy was assassinated in Dallas and
so we can tell that you know sod there
was a person named John F Kennedy and he
was killed in Dallas and that
information is then captured with you
know machine learning artificial or
artificial intelligence but it takes
someone with contextual knowledge to
know who John F Kennedy
so my point is that while machine
learning and deep learning can snow who
was assassinated
but the relevance and the significance
of that is something that you require
context and that's why all of our
curators are at least MDS or PhD level
skill to do that curation I don't think
machine learning and the natural
language processing has quite gotten to
the level of sophistication as a person
with an MD or PhD degree and more
recently an announcement by IBM Watson
to sort of scale down their IBM health
efforts really speaks to the
sophistication we have today with
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and that is that while it's
very promising we're probably not going
to replace human curated at least for
the next couple of years and so we want
to provide a high quality product and
that's why we're committed to focusing
on manual curation for now until the
technology for natural language
processing and artificial intelligence
improves that's not to say we won't do
it in the future it's just that for now
we still believe that you know years
decades of training is still the best
way to provide high quality clinical
decision support data I would like to
once again thank doctor yet for his
presentation I would also like to take
kyochon for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2018 you will
receive an email from laborat
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye